welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
every Friday at twitch.tv /a Street
reductions thank you to our sponsors
today Boland branch Dollar Shave Club
audible and equipped today's guest the
wonderful prolific hilarious talented
Shane Dawson recently passed 12 million
subscribers on your now main channel yes
congratulations on that and thank you so
much for coming and joining us I'm
really happy to have you here it's so
cool to meet you so yeah thanks for
coming today are you very nervous I
always say something that just I don't
know I get in trouble right well it's
live great you know it's funny I've it's
like what can you do you know it's part
of the magic right the first episode we
did live
I made some we had a filthy Frank here I
don't even know how we got in this
conversation about like rape and nature
settings like how animals rape each
other right and I was like yeah I was
just saying some stupid [ __ ]
I don't know how why would I even be
talking about that and I say something
that sounded really bad and George is
sitting behind it goes and that haunts
me forever so if you can drop that I
want to say before we get too deep and
if you guys have questions for Shane
about him ghost stories conspiracy
theories whatever is on your mind give
us a ring at one eight one eight two one
four eight
5:04 god bless him I want to get right
in to the juice okay okay we had spoken
a couple weeks back when all this
Twitter garbage was exploding about
there was allegations and let me just
say utter and stupid absolute trash and
garbage that you are a pedophile yes
tell me about how how did you find out
about this it was crazy the night before
it happened I got a DM from keemstar I
thought as I made a joke that Dana
videos saying like Oh
keemstar is gonna DME about being a
child molester cuz I flew out a fan who
was 14 to my house interesting and I
made like a joke what a twist I know two
days before that in a MOOC bang with
Trisha Paytas a MOOC Bank it's where you
order a lot of food when you eat it on
camera
I've heard of a bank a joke about how
you go eat one meal and then immediately
eat another meal that's my life I just
thought that was I never heard of that I
might be saying it wrong it might be
mukbang either way sounds I love bank
and food somehow it's great I'll get to
the gangbang in a second Christ no but I
made a joke saying like you know my
friend was like oh ho people like you
right now and I'm like well it comes in
waves like in you know every two years
people hate me and I said and it's
ticking like two years is coming so like
by tomorrow something Bad's gonna happen
I'm gonna be like whatever and literally
ya the next day anyways so I thought the
video was a joke like I thought it was a
parody because of the way it was edited
it said I because my boyfriend and
previous girlfriend have baby faces I
want to [ __ ] a babies I'm like clearly
this is a joke right
and then yeah it just became a thing
it's just so stupid it was the channel
was pop blast hmm
as everybody knows some respects table
interestingly they made the video called
Shane Dawson is a pedophile that was the
title of it here's proof it had the
channel I'm really actually happy to say
that YouTube just straight up and
deleted it yeah they're like smell you
later idiots but the thing that really
twisted my panties into a full not was
like this stupid rip reputation las'
channel makes a video and Twitter
flippin news it's the number I open
because Twitter news people respect the
people look at it now yeah you click the
thing number one you had like the
flagship story a legate people are
saying Shane Dawson's a pedophile for 48
hours which they've never done before
like in America even with the shootings
three hours after the shooting in
Florida it was like this sushi roll has
amazed
okay that deserves longer than you know
but it was crazy so the craziest part
was there was no allegation like it was
literally so dumb literally me talking
about [ __ ] babies or something on a
podcast which was stupid
five or six years ago but that's not now
like geisha she's making a joke yeah no
kid came forward or no parent award it's
like oh whatever people are saying yeah
so that was a confusing part and I had
people at the gym you know like looking
at me weird and humility Starbucks
looking at me weird and it was a thing
people thought I was a [ __ ] pedophile
for cuz of her news yeah the it actually
was even it this conspiracy had legs
like there was even it wouldn't even a
level further people were saying Logan
Paul's manager paid money to get the
video up to take heat off him I guess it
was right after the dead body yeah I
think what happened was I think it was a
parody I think the person who made it
liked my conspiracy videos know who I'm
gonna like make one about Shane okay
clearly a joke and then because it it
went too far and somebody cut it up even
more and put it on Twitter they took not
the jokey parts and I think that person
was like oh no okay how do I make it
obvious that this was fake so then they
started putting out these weird like
clues and then the Logan Paul email and
and then their channel got deleted so oh
that sucks for them if it was just like
meant to me I think it was because it
was so stupid right there evidence of me
[ __ ] my boyfriend who has a baby food
yeah that's so crazy that I'm like and
there was scary music under it so I
think it was a joke than what you fart
and then the news because poor son of a
[ __ ] was trying to make like a homage
to you in a way maybe once you know once
it got like out of hand
that's I don't know I can't think of the
alternative because it's like well if it
was some person that was trying to ruin
my life they wouldn't have put the
baby-faced stuff in there you know what
I mean so who was it and it was well
edited hmm so are they ha because I just
find it so disturbing that Twitter
broadcasted that as if it was something
serious for so long yeah was there any
repercussions to that oh my god yeah
it was it was nuts personally it was
nuts my family it was really bad just
because like that word is so triggering
sure you know like I've been molested
like it's a long-running thing in my
family it's very I'm very anti pedophile
like everybody else but no but from a
personal yeah and all my I've done so
many videos about child molesters in
Hollywood and I'm like very actively
like trying to shut that [ __ ] down so
when it came back at me and people
called me a pedophile that's the worst
thing they could call me literally the
worst I can't think of anything else
yeah but yeah money-wise it [ __ ] me up
it I lost you know brand deals and I my
certain things that were supposed to
happen are happening anymore just
because of that
dude that's and even now that it's kind
of like I'm settled you still have lost
those connections everybody says it's
not why like oh no it's other reasons
like oh this this one away because of
other things I'm like really like it
happened two days after the pedophile
thing and then it just went away
did you hear what about like YouTube how
did they react because they're so
sensitive to everything these days they
were supportive they know they know they
were like listen we know you didn't do
anything but like you know it's hot off
the heels of low compulsion but handle
another greater controversy yeah but
they were like you know it was very much
like let's see what happens and the
story died pretty quickly
yeah it's not a story I didn't [ __ ] it's
like there is no story there's nowhere
to go oh the best though was like all
the websites the news websites that
we're doing stories on it one of them
used a picture of me holding a baby doll
it's like from Instagram of me like
holding baby dolls because it's like a
sex toy or something yeah what that was
the craziest part dude it's so crazy to
me that like something on this scale
with no merit at all yeah it's like this
me too thing is so click worthy or like
these allegations are
nobody's even thinking it twice about it
but what about like I don't know do some
research like especially as a brand
watch the video all of a sudden is gonna
cancel somewhere yeah you know are you
not gonna check like you I can just say
it about anyone but that's it it's so
dangerous now because even if they
watched it and they're like this is
stupid
people are gonna have that Association
and we just don't want that yeah people
are gonna hold it against them yeah yeah
what was crazy with some youtubers were
like some people in general we're
tweeting things oh you should have made
those jokes or you shouldn't have had
that conversation on a podcast whatever
and kind of making it seem like it was
my fault which I understand but also
like a lot of those people I'm like you
know this could happen to anybody
laughs like they took a thing from six
years ago and edited it imagine like all
of us have hours of content yeah could
happen to anybody
anyone cleanest person in the world I
just Dean who knows I I completely agree
it could happen to anyone
there's no question about it I have some
old videos boy but also they should all
be unlisted now it's a huge difference I
think we will need to make the
difference between like you made a
shitty joke that you shouldn't have made
to this guy's a pedophile that's insane
they are so far from each other yeah
it's such a jump well one of the points
you brought up that I something that
infuriates me is that there are
suspected and arrested pedophiles and
sexual abusers who are working in
Hollywood right now and people are
wasting their time talking about that
[ __ ] um you know about this guy
Bryan Singer I've talked about him on
the podcast here before what do you know
about Bryan Singer what do you say like
that that is like I have filmed a
conspiracy video about him six times and
I always edit him out because I'm scared
it's dangerous
oh oh he's scary it's [ __ ] up so you
know probably that meant several people
have brought lawsuits against him that
have mysteriously and inexplicably
been dropped for no reason you know
other than oh I changed my mind I mean
there's a whole documentary about ya
know pain and that wig dude
open secret creaking and so decided
herbed me so much yeah and that the
woman who directed it like what two
years before that she won an Oscar for
her previous documentary and people are
like she's the next big thing the second
she released that blacklisted from
everybody are you serious yeah cuz I
mean she's opening I've been on the
YouTube side of it not to say you know
here I go conspiracy but you know I
talked about the child porn on YouTube
like two years ago like the spider-man
else's show even worse there's even
darker [ __ ] people like like parents who
dress up like a doctor and pull kids
pants down put syringe and like these
crazy channels that I've been talking
about for two years telling YouTube hey
everybody in my agents everybody take it
down take ten bro I have the same
experience and they're like mmm they're
like Shane I'm gonna blacklist you very
much like shut up right on of me which
makes me think you think I'm the way
that I see it I think that's giving them
too much credit
mm-hm think they're more like they just
always have a problem right they're
always dealing with something and you
think of YouTube is like a we're a bunch
of slick-ass tech guys and everything's
under control
there's like 20 people like high up
there who are doing everything I feel
like yeah and what's hard from their
point of view is like where do you draw
the line on stuff like when is a
spider-man also video okay and when is
it not yeah it's kind of hard to say
like can you tailor a rat if it's dead
at what point there are channels who
have done it and I don't know
like Liza Coe she you know has a video
and I love her has a video where she's
like stabbing a dead fish
really which like me whatever it's it's
a whatever but so is that that different
that different it still is [ __ ] up I
would never teach her rap no like it's
like a weird like we're is the line yeah
it's it's a tough job that they have
it's it is a tough job
I was just twitch just came out with new
guidelines and it's just funny the
position these companies are in now
because a lot of people have been
like Teddy streamers on Twitch and so
they made these new guidelines were like
okay you can wear a dress like this is
okay this is okay this isn't okay like
they actually have like a gradient of
cleavage show as now that's acceptable
but it's kind of ridiculous to be in
that position you know which isn't okay
so twitch yes so that's not like camphor
there it's there's not like a porn
section of it no there should be Frank
they're looking for more traffic well I
guess a lot of people on twitch twitch
streamers complain that girls they like
to work for tips and stuff like that the
problem with twitch bromwich though is
that unlike YouTube where there's enough
there's enough space for everyone
because you can watch one video you can
watch another video on Twitch you've got
live broadcast and you can't enjoy
everyone at once so they're like this
working for tips and I'm trying to be
entertaining here and I can't compete
with them [ __ ] titties I got a helmet
on my second monitor you guys know my
titties yeah they don't have to that's
it's a competitive advantage that's
something that's going on in the world
Brian finger oh wait
that guy is a he just the guy he's made
so many movies and shows and he's still
making a ton of [ __ ] with like the
highest of people in Hollywood like damn
well he so in the open secret you saw
the one of his little partners back in
the day mm-hmm is now really high up in
Bitcoin really I didn't think maybe it
wasn't in the documentary but yeah it's
everything is so connected so it's
creepy
oh sorry we have a soundboard and that's
it that's Carlos for the connect why are
pedophiles so well organized because
it's it's about power
hmm oh that's interesting I think
pedophiles this is gonna get me [ __ ]
in whatever whatever I genuinely do
think though that there is like a lot of
people in power that are because it is
about when you have billions of dollars
and you have make sense you get bored
right and you're kind of [ __ ] up and
evil it's like so it's like how else
that's dark just like man I'm bored I'm
gonna go [ __ ] a baby you look at the
Bible not that I like read the Bible or
whatever but but if you look though like
that in history it's like people have
that high of power turn to murder they
turn to pedophilia they turn to you know
mmm all the dark [ __ ] because they're
[ __ ] bored hostile like stabbing
people for money it's just like you know
I do find what you said interesting
about power because it's clearly is a
power thing the whole pedophile and I
think someone who that appeals to also
would love being in a position of money
and power and controlling people and I
don't even know though if it's like I
don't even think they start out as
Pettit like those types of people I
don't even think they start out as
pedophile I think it's like a it's in
there but I think it just they develop a
taste for it well there's also this
company that like sells young blood draw
me dude you've got my all the weirdest
tell me about this there's a company
that sells young I've never even heard
that term you sell like a middle one I
don't remember where it's happening does
that cannibalism maybe I'd sell my blood
honestly at this point you probably
would get a polymer trouble mm-hmm crime
I'll just give it to you right a blood
prime amazon would love that and I met
young as in like 18 I'm not talking
about okay okay I don't know good all
right horrible house this whole but
going back has do you feel like the
whole allegations have settled against
you do you feel like it's all laid to
rest now right yeah I mean I'm not a
pedophile so it's like this thing of for
me it was more like okay I'm
pedophile so where do we go where I like
when you know other things have happened
with my other bad jokes I've made in the
past like I have this guilt and I feel
like constantly like I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry but this mic I'm not
a pedophile so can we you know what I
mean and I think people did move on yeah
I mean all your all all of your
colleagues on YouTube everyone was just
like this is so stupid
yeah so there's that that always is nice
to see it seems like you've made a
significant like shift and your content
and how you manage your channel and
everything and I know that as a youtuber
knowing a lot of youtubers that's one of
the hardest things to do is to make like
a huge shift or to reinvent yourself
especially in a way where your fans like
and it seems like your channel is doing
I don't know better than ever can you
say that it's doing great let's say that
how did you manage to pull that off I
mean now tell me run tell me about your
thought process going through that I
kind of subconsciously change it every
year interesting I think just because
for me I get a little bored and then you
know but this this this specific year
was different because I for the last you
know 10 years my thought process was
like oh I need to get off of youtube I
need it this is just I'm gonna make
movies and TV and this and that and then
I kind of came to the conclusion that
like oh no like [ __ ] like YouTube is
really cool and people actually are
starting to respect it more and like I
should just make [ __ ] I would make on TV
or movies on my channel so that's kind
of what I've been doing it's a lot more
work I want more money and you know
stuff but I'm actually like really proud
of it now like a year ago I don't know
if I would have said I was of that proud
of like eating pizza on camera you know
you can tell that your production
quality is definitely really impressive
now it feels like I'm watching a show oh
that's it's yeah it's right and like
you're doing it every day yeah that's
gotta be pretty nutty yeah I mean now
it's kind of [ __ ] up like sometimes
it's just three videos a week or
sometimes even just two just because
they're like 30
really long yeah and it's just me and
one other person editing all of them and
that's I was wondering if you edit yeah
I used to I've brought in people but the
one I'm using now his name is Andrew he
films and edits because it usually does
one and I do too or he just do I do one
we trade off no it's a lot that's
awesome man
yeah it's super hard to get someone to
edit your is is this guy a new editor
how long has he been editing stuff for
you I didn't even know how new he
literally started editing like a few
months before he added it with me really
yeah he was working a learner and yeah
he's very very quick learner and really
good and got me excited again about
editing because I think now I'm just
like Loni dad and everything - was it
hard to pass that up that responsibility
off to somebody you get like possessive
about your editing abilities it's
getting harder the more invested I am in
when this [ __ ] my conspiracy videos now
I can't imagine anybody editing them
besides me because I'm so invested in it
right right right
um but it is hard to like I don't know
if you guys deal with I have a lot of
issues with like myself editing myself
that off like usually used to just be
one angle eating pizza in the kitchen
this angle no double chin because the
cameras high now it's like me [ __ ]
running around your body
you know that's been hard for me to look
at and it's been triggering I feel like
mark part of what's triggering for every
youtuber is watching themselves and
listening to themselves so much I saw
your I do like that when I said it I
want to talk about that cuz I have a lot
to say about that you too yeah but we're
gonna take a quick commercial break and
do not go away we will be right back so
god bless thank you to Bowen brands for
sponsoring this episode of the h3
podcast we may disagree on many things
but here's one thing we can all agree on
you need more sleep yes you watching
right now you specifically and here's
how to get it you don't need to buy an
expensive mattress you don't need
sleeping pills or any non
since like that all you may need is to
change your sheets now I've got the
bowline branch package and I'm happy to
say that I feel like a Greek goddess
finally I've always felt like a Greek
goddess inside and now rolling around in
these silky smooth unbelievable sheets I
feel that I've ascended and that people
are launching ships in my name because
I'm so beautiful and flowing you've
always looked like a Great Goddess
I finally Bowl and branch will bring out
the Greek goddess in within you because
of these luxurious sheets everything
they make from bedding the blankets is
made pure 100% organic cotton which
means that they start out super soft and
they get even softer over time
what else does if they age like wine
it's basically what they're saying these
are sheets that age like wine my sheets
from my childhood
they just ball up into little cottage
mutts they gets stuck in your like pubes
and disintegrates this doesn't
disintegrate it gets him better you can
buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in a store but with bowling ball
and branch you're getting the same exact
quality but for only a couple hundred
bucks everybody who tries Boleyn branch
loves them myself included sometimes
I'll just be in my bedroom and I'll glut
and I'll grab like the pillowcase and
I'll just be like I'll just rub it and
then maybe I'll if I'm really it's been
a really intense day I'll just kind of
try to suffocate myself with it that's
unrelated to the quality of the sheets
but you go out in style maybe the fact
that everyone loves them and giving them
five star reviews including Forbes and
Wall Street Journal and Fast Company and
that everybody's talking about Boleyn
branch is for a reason probably because
they're great even three u.s. presidents
sleep on ball and branch sheets read it
and weep how are you president who are
you to question that you will feel like
I won't feel like a president and a
Greek goddess shipping is here if you're
in doubt listen no shipping is free and
you can try them for 30 nights
risk-free if you don't love them you
send them back and get a refund I doubt
you're going to even if you're like I'm
gonna get free sheets for 30 days I'm a
little sneaker no you're gonna want to
keep them because they're that good
I'm not couraging that behavior by the
way no but okay there's no risk there's
no reason not to give them a try
to get started right now for my
listeners you get $50 off your first set
of sheets at Boland branch calm use the
promo code h3 go to bull and branch calm
today for $50 off your first set of
sheets that's bol el and branch dot-com
slap a promo code no / promo code h3
Bolin brace calm promo code h-street if
you are looking for some new sheets my
friends please consider supporting them
and help support our show your
girlfriend is gonna be like what she's
gonna propose to you
next up yeah big thank you to Dollar
Shave Club for supporting us with
thousands of athletes going for the gold
right now it's got me thinking with all
the Dollar Shave club's been doing
lately they're the clear champions of
the bathroom and I think they deserve a
gold medal don't you ela I've always
thought that they relied Olympics on
like dollars yeah this guy who just did
like 30 flips on ice skates is dope
but where's Dollar Shave club's gold at
Dolce Club calm they deliver everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best Dollar Shave Club is more than just
razors and by the way if their razors
are the best they've got these a meaty
weighty heavy executive razors that are
just they're the only razor I use cuz it
doesn't give me razor burn what more
reason do you need then that I use it
for cleaning up like the edge here and
here the most useful thing I found to
use is cleaning up my neckline just
glide that like but I do it and all of a
sudden I don't have to be a freak with a
hairy neck that I've walked around being
like a like a looking like a eight man
I'm like oh my god just use the razor
back here when you're in the shower it's
unbelievable makes such a huge
difference
Ethan's beauty tips I'm going for the
Silver Dollar Shave Club has everything
I mean everything you need to look smell
and feel your best shampoo body wash
toothpaste and of course the best razor
I've ever used why waste time in the
store asking some thirteen-year-old
pimply-faced
nerd what his recommendation on is
razors listen to me they're the best
don't waste your time just buy this I
get an amazing high-quality shave every
morning from Dollar Shave Club executive
razor and the true gold standard of any
morning routine is their shave Carver's
shave butter here it is it helps the
razor glide gently across the skin I
have incidentally tried melting real
butter and dipping my razor into that
matter I damn don't don't do that
use their shea butter it works better
trust me
they deliver everything to you that
means no more trips to the store
wandering around like Moses through the
desert hunting for razors shampoo
toothpaste my god we're taking time out
of your day to go shopping so you can
play a cashier or what all of a sudden
you got to scan your own stuff
get real won't they just pay you while
you're at it be their employee go for
the gold
join Dollar Shave Club today for just
five dollars with Free Shipping and
you'll get their [ __ ] shower shave
starter set and don't even talk to me
about their bud wipes that you get
included that brings me back to my
beautiful childhood days when you would
wipe once and be done these days I'm 30
years old my body's falling apart I'm
baking a cake in the toilet
somebody told there's like 30 wipes at
once your this wouldn't say no but I
know what you know what I mean you're I
don't want to know what you might your
turn 30 that's the amount of wipes it
takes well with their one wipe charlie
that's what all it takes one way relive
those glory days it has a six blade
executive razor plus trial size of shave
butter body cleanser and wild wipe
Charlies then keep the blades coming for
a few bucks a month get yours at
dollarshaveclub.com slash h3 that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash h3 thank you
to ballin brancion and Dollar Shave Club
supporting us if you are in the market
for either of those products please
consider supporting them to help support
the show thank you all let us get right
back into it
welcome back to the HB podcast we were
talking about hating ourselves
[Laughter]
I feel like somewhere along when I was a
young lad 13 years old I would stare at
pictures of if I saw a picture of myself
it would ruin my whole [ __ ] day yeah
I would stare at myself in the mirror
and just be like I [ __ ] hate you're
so ugly and I it was we got so unhealthy
that I said you know what every time I
look at myself in the mirror in a
picture I get so depressed and anxious
I'm gonna stop for a whole year I didn't
look at mirrors I didn't look at
pictures of myself I didn't care and I
feel like somehow through this this like
a I don't know a pilgrimage I know I
don't care I don't care how fat how ugly
how disgusting I look on camera or
pictures I'm just like yeah I'm a
[ __ ] monster like I've accepted it
I'm just like yeah I'm a monster I know
that but it doesn't bother me right oh
that's sad is it okay to get like sad
I'm not like yeah hi okay first art is
what I'm gonna say is I think it's like
not that we like mirrors but it is like
looking at me right now because I'm the
same way
and for me I would tell you like what
you're crazy what are you talking about
you're not a monster you're not fat
you're not ugly like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you're crazy right and
that's what my friends tell me that's
what my boyfriend tells me that's what
my therapist everybody has told me that
but like it's literally like shut up
you're lying you're lying in line I'll
never believe you but so yeah the last
year I did the same thing I was like you
know what like I'm just not gonna like
look at any pictures not my tagged
pictures I'm not gonna like a little bit
literally anything and it helps
sometimes like I'll have like a good
week and then like yeah
today like it hit me again and I was
just like I literally want to get out of
my body and go somewhere else
like he's just like I'm [ __ ] done I'm
[ __ ] done I'm over it and you know
and so yeah I don't know I feels like
there's no cure hi
you know and it's just like I don't know
it's it's crazy that we're all like no
that's what we do yeah we literally put
ourself like you recovered from it but I
feel like actually salmon's you're
describing and it's it's just weird that
you can't like grow when I get over it I
don't know it's so strange you would
think that I would get over it
a certain time when you do videos every
week and podcast yeah I don't know if it
says extreme but I like I hate like when
Ethan is editing a video or something
and I have to watch it I just I almost
just don't even want to look
she makes me cut a lot or like when your
voice is heard or when your but and I
know that everyone listening would be
like what is wrong with you you're crazy
you're being crazy
yeah I know what used to always piss me
off I would be looking at a picture of
myself and I'd be like this is the worst
picture of me ever and then my mom would
walk up and she be back what are you
talking about that's just how you look
like I want you to tell me that's a bad
picture oh my god really like I've been
the most triggered since maybe four
years ago I hadn't worn shorts in 15
years or something and I was on the
beach with my girlfriend at the time and
I was like I'm just gonna wear shorts I
don't [ __ ] it I'm gonna do it I'm happy
right now I'm just gonna do it and I
think I was even twenty pounds lighter
than I am now and I was walking around
with shorts on and a girl took a picture
with me and she was a nice kid and then
she posted on instagram with hashtag
fatter in person and like what's a
fellow I know but it's like no matter
how much my girlfriend other times like
you don't look fat you don't look fat
I'm like this girl is firmed it but you
can't back down
that's the conspiracy that
she proved hey guys you know she proved
it like I was like there's nothing you
person is wrong with you you know who's
a fan of yours and then I look back at
that picture and I'm like I wish I was
that fat yeah oh my god - because like
all the people watching and stuff and
people that watch us like they like look
at that's not like role model it's the
wrong word but they look at us like oh I
wish I want to do that like I like these
people whatever and we're all sitting
here like I wish I could be a better
like you know like it gets better like
it doesn't if you have issues with your
looks that's one of the things that
depresses me in general and having
achieve some level of success that
people want themselves is that you're
always like why aren't I happier and
just like the self-awareness of that
fuels me feeling bad it's twisted his
twisted did yeah I literally got a text
when I was in the bathroom just now I
got a text from a friend and they were
just like hey by the way like you look
really good on camera I can tell you're
nervous about it but you look okay right
now and I was just like when I saw you I
thought you look great yeah person yeah
[Music]
over 10 years ah married for five yeah
that's why I like when the whole online
dating thing happened I was like I
didn't want to do it at first because
that's the fear because that's a fatter
in person and they don't want to [ __ ]
you yeah I mean right they see you in
person from your pictures now honestly
you know what cured me is having ELA and
she's like Marge Simpson where she's
like don't exercise too hard homie I owe
[ __ ] what if I was single but I've been
with either for so long that like you
know they even the necessity of looking
good
I should probably care more I should
probably look good for her more but she
she gives me a level of comfort that I
haven't been together for so long
it is mutual Ethan helps me in getting a
lot more confidence than I you like I
was way worse before than a confidence
machine machine it's in my garage at
home but didn't change your life I'll
make sure you get it right on this it's
a it's a you stand on it and it just
does this it's just shakes it just
shakes but it's so funny that we called
confidence Tennessee no I've tried that
God are you trigger machine like my skin
is like a saw and like a little loose
not like crazy I had surgery so it's not
that crazy but like yeah if I jiggle
it's a jiggle confidence machine yeah
it's a misnomer for sure my ass was like
yeah [ __ ] watch out car TV here
whoever's got that big ass big ass is
white that's the thing like what's her
name kim kardashian if you look at
before-and-afters
her body's on if you look from five
years ago she's like hey I'm a normal
lady who's fit to now she's like I'm a
Barbie doll and my waist it looks like
somebody who strangled me with a corset
for a decade yeah I hope that like big
leg two men become a thing tree trunks
my dude yes I got [ __ ] thick leg ass
dirt I told I said yesterday my friend I
said I'm the shape of a chocolate Easter
Bunny yes with your fat legs daddy like
that everything I would maybe looking at
me beauty in our society yeah I was just
gonna say that I have more
a pear shape I have a very pear shape I
don't think so and I love you got a seat
bro you're being so here's the thing
you're being nice no I do have a
conspiracy though about like not the fat
ass thing but I noticed that like
fashion lately has been going more
toward people gaining weight yeah we all
kind of are so late
yeah like when I went to a store I never
go shopping but I went to a store to
look for a new shirt and like all the
guys shirt we're like really long and
like oversized and then I saw like
Bieber all these people wearing them and
I'm like no this is a fashion industry
like here Shane here's a big shirt to
hide it is a big comfortable shirt that
we're gonna call a fashion like and now
we're all wearing these big I mean I'm
not wearing this but no I have noticed
that people like like you were saying
where the 6xl is that yeah to cover your
ass and like to cover your just need I
need a burka honestly I think the
fashion where it got really criticized
for like being in support of like
anorexia almost maybe that's a result of
that and not trying to shame you shame
but but that is true all the models were
were like pretty much an arrest they got
a lot of [ __ ] for it
you know it's disgusting why would they
even want that does the clothes look
better honestly if you're just like a
little it's like a human hanger yeah
yeah that's funny yeah I wish I could
wear a graduation gown like all the time
yeah Momo yes you seen that Simpsons a
second time I quoted Simpsons when
Holmes started wearing a muumuu I love
that episode yeah my grandma when my
grandma died well the first one died and
she lived in a moon she lived in a chair
she was very big she lived in a chair on
a trailer and when she died we got all
her movies and my mom kept them and I
theory I think she was keeping them for
me because because five years after that
I would I hid around for hunting and my
Maru series or hundy bro fo hundy wow
that's almost like what boogie
was weighing at his max he was that like
500 yet his mattress - yeah I held it
well I looked like I was on you know
like when actor is going to fat suits
but like they don't have the gloves or
the neck yet right so I had like a thin
small little thin handle big body right
my legs still are about the same size
big boys but that was like 10 years ago
11 years ago so yeah that's unbelievable
I saw a picture of you like I don't know
if it was in high school or middle
school and I I didn't even know it was
you
yeah how did you make the transfer that
transformation um I mean I had been on
like Weight Watchers since I was like 5
like my mom was always trying and I was
always like you know losing weight
gaining weight losing weight um and then
yeah I round 18 I was graduating high
school and I was like no I'm just gonna
do this officially I'm done like I don't
to go to school anymore so I'll just
bend all my time like eating right and
running because I had me you just set
your mind to it you're like you know
what [ __ ] this yeah I was like gonna go
to college I'm gonna lose weight instead
which is what I did well that's good
because I went to college and gained
weight on my experience yeah you don't
go where you going yeah I was a little
twink man when I went off to college I
weighed 130
that's my Lyme leg and how I'm like 200
yeah I want to talk actually you know
what let's take a call I was like you've
been inactive for 60 minutes click ok to
resume all right
resume who we got Bri oh we have two
people on the line hello Briana and
Josie what how are you guys hey oh they
drop wait wait what happened they were
so excited okay hold on hold on hold on
okay are you guys there hello
oh yeah we're okay god bless you hey
guys how are you
we're pretty good have a question for
Shane um yeah we have a question
for shame first of all we love you so
much and my friend is freaking out right
now wow that's nice and we are question
for us our question is what are you trip
lands for videos Bobby burns hi guys
sorry I didn't know if you could hear me
or another yeah do I look fat no
screenshot into either okay thank you
oh yeah yes I anyway thank you guys for
the question god bless you appreciate
you which is the best drop feeling on
this story for yes so I found this hater
hater video and I was like oh this kids
good so I flew him out to LA and it's of
videos with him and then was like oh I
want him to do some videos for my
channel because I don't really I'm not
good at that type of videos like
critical you know I'm I'm talking to
camera about stuff like that and so yeah
now we're trying to make a show for my
channel for him to do I followed the
whole thing I thought I was fascinated
by it
this guy Bobby Lee burns Bobby burns he
made a really critical video about you I
think I have a exerpeutic terrible
content invite this guy out and and
harness his power yeah he didn't call me
fat but to be fair that is not a fair
attack on someone and I feel like that's
a fair thing to say about him because
like calling someone fat is different
than saying like I don't like your
content remember right yeah so how did
you guys make that connection you and
Bobby
ice Bobby burns yeah I saw the video on
Thanksgiving and I like went off into
another room because I was like I want
to like tweet him or DM him or something
to show that like because what bothered
me was at the end of the video he said I
know this video is gonna make it so I
never get to work with Shane ever but he
thought that that was gonna like he was
like burning a bridge or something yeah
and then I was like that's not like who
do you think and he's talking about how
rich he thinks I am and all these things
I'm like who
you have such a misconception of you to
like most of us aren't making that much
because the ads are so [ __ ]
yeah and also like I'm I am okay with
criticism I like we talked about hate
myself
yeah by the way
when someone makes fun of your content
does it upset you in the same way as one
likes body image things I don't care all
right so so in a way you know you give
and take some things oh yeah and then
and also he was calling my conspiracy
videos terrible and I full-heartedly
don't believe that because I love making
them so for me I understand if he didn't
like them but for me I'm like well if he
was calling like my pizza eating videos
terrible I'd be like I get it yeah but
like like whatever but I like the way he
edited in the way that he shot stuff so
yeah i DM him and he was like oh and
then like he's I probably surprised yeah
and then yeah I flew him out he's a
sweet kid he's like 21 yeah so he's
making a second show that's gonna be on
your channel or what yeah I've always
given the weekends to like newer younger
people like this girl Alexis geez all
who was just starting out a few years
ago I let her take over Sundays right
now have another youtuber named Esther
he takes over Saturdays I've always just
given my weekend to like you know
smaller people who like I don't know
I've always done that so Bobby I was
like oh that makes sense
some days on my channel we'll see how it
goes nice nice I'll tune in I'll see
what Bobby's got to say seem to make a
video talking [ __ ] about batter everyday
we got one more call from Isabel hello
Isabella hey hey how are you
hey what's up you got a question good
you have a question for sure so first I
just want to say Shane I met you at your
book tour and I like couldn't say a word
to you so hi
anyway my question is can you give us
any insight on like what scary haunted
place you're gonna go to next trade
secrets thank you for your question
Isabel
bless you am i saying your name right
Isabella Isabelle drops yeah you're
saying it right
oh yes scary stuff oh wait so you guys
are into ghosts up - right right so it's
kind of a weird thing I'm not a believer
okay but I want to bleep a believer and
every time we have a guest I ask them
what should ghost story because it's
like oh it's a weird parent where I'm a
very skeptical person but I don't know
our fans love it so every time we are
here we say hey what's your best ghost
story sometimes they don't have one
sometimes I got a great one I am
expecting there's a lot of ghost
discussion to happen here must have been
from Austin oh well small it's like a
big ghost guy okay he took me on a ghost
hunt mm-hmm and I was such a skeptical
[ __ ] that I was just goofing the
whole time but I guess you have to
suspend your disbelief when you're doing
that is that how you feel are you
genuinely like they're spooks to be had
right here real spoofs i well so my
boyfriend is is like you very skeptical
hmm and every time we've done something
goes hunting he has a crazy experience
and it's almost like he [ __ ] forgets
it the next day my kill mommy he'll hear
a voice something will happen something
should touch him and whatever and he's
freaked out in the moment then the next
day he's like I don't know maybe it was
just like the [ __ ] wind or some time
like we have it on camera so I think if
you're a skeptical person nothing will
really change that maybe for me I was I
used to be skeptical and then when I was
11 I was laying in my bed
and I felt like fingers on my back like
a like one of these and I heard happy
birthday and I thought it was just my
mom so then either your birthday yeah I
had like a really bad birthday and I'm
sad whatever so I thought I was just my
mom and then I turn over and there's
nobody there yeah I was like whoa so I
run into my mom's room and at the time
my mom's really religious at the time my
mom's like oh honey that was just your
guardian angel she knew he had a bad day
or whatever so at the time I was like
okay mom love the Bible yeah later on in
life I'm like wait a minute
that's what [ __ ]
something [ __ ] up um and then when I
was 22 or something my dead grandma my
grandma died like a week prior and then
I was sad and I looked up I was like 11
p.m.
watching friends look over and my
grandma's standing in my closet like
right there you just saw your grandma
full-form yes staring yes like standing
there in my closet like what was the
vibe I was wearing a purple robe was it
always wore was it like a friendly
visitation
it was like it was dark in my room
because I was watching TV at night and
when I looked over she was standing
there and it was a little dark but I
still completely saw her and her face
and she was just kind of blank faced and
I like froze and I didn't know what to
do and have you ever like thought
something bad was happening and you just
freeze and you don't know what to do so
I did that did that do that and then I
got enough energy to run out of the room
like we were staring for a long time it
felt like an hour but it's probably you
know ten seconds or something okay yeah
and I just look at this and then I ran
out of the room like barf like it was
like really [ __ ] up and intense my
brother ran my mom they met me in the
hallway and the craziest part was my
brother goes did you see grandma when I
was like and he's like 27 at the time
did I seriously god I never experienced
anything like that why did he ask that I
and I was just like oh my God my God my
God he goes because right before you
started screaming he's like I could feel
her and he had her coffee table in his
room and he's like and I looked down at
the coffee table and like I just like
saw what I thought was her in the glass
of it and then my mom was like I smelled
her because she wore the same perfume
all the time like we all the same
experience at the same moment which is
crazy because my brother is total
skeptic but he's like I thought what you
saw her was your grandma a very big part
of your life up until then she pretty
much raised me and my mom was working a
lot just down so my grandma so she lived
with you guys well this is the most
[ __ ] up part so I'm we go back to my
bedroom we're all holding hands
my mom's crying like we would like walk
in and I'm there like where did you see
her and I pointed and my brother goes
dude look what the [ __ ] you're pointing
at I was pointing at her purple robe
that she wore every day cuz that's the
one thing I kept when she died cousin I
just want to remember her and it was
hanging in my closet she was standing
right in front of
in it yeah I guess that's crazy
so then I went to a medium and I didn't
even at the time really believe in
mediums but my girlfriend Thomas I so
median is someone who talks to the dead
was that right the Long Island yeah and
this lady like doesn't did she have
crazy hair it was in her basement which
was a little scary okay she like solves
murders she works with the FBI like she
doesn't really do it for people unless
they're family friends so she did it for
me
okay and before I even told her anything
she was like your grandma's here and she
wants to talk to you and everything she
said was stuff I had never talked about
it was like your grandma knows about
your you know eating disorder your
grandma knows about this and this and
this and like you are getting towards
death if you don't figure your [ __ ] out
and I was I was bad as well yeah and my
uncle who I never told anybody this my
uncle killed himself and I was really
close to him and she goes and your
uncle's here that she knew was a name
and everything and she's like and he
does not want you to do it cuz I was
pretty suicide all the time geez he's
standing behind me if that was when it
was just like you must have just been
like how [ __ ] I lecture it yeah I was
just like oh my god like this is all
very real it's not like huh and dark and
that did change my life you know um that
would be a very formative experience in
my life yeah yes so how old were you
when you spoke with the medium that was
Sperry 22 23 and that sparked your and
those serious events about you interests
and ghosts and stuff yeah so how do you
see it now like do you see ghosts as in
hindsight was that a friendly visitation
what was it was it something that which
is your grandma spirit conscious was a
ghost conscious or was she just kind of
there unconsciously floating there you
know what I mean
yeah I think energy like energy can't go
away so I think when somebody dies their
energy is still somewhere so I think
from what the medium said you know when
my grandma needed to tell me something
or pop talk to me she showed up in the
forum that I remembered her ass but
that's like not what she is on the other
side okay so I don't really know I think
everything's on different look like you
know your dog can hear certain sounds
that weekend
and dogs and cats and stuff can see
ghosts supposedly I think they're just
on a slightly different level than we
are and then we're like right under it
so maybe maybe the ghosts are all around
us we just can't see it so what I own
you're in your ghost investigating
what's the craziest [ __ ] you've
encountered we recently we went to the
Queen Mary which is like the most
haunted ship in the world a ship yeah a
ship Hotel bigger than the Titanic twice
as biggest is it just like a museum now
or is it still the hotel now yeah oh is
it like a is it marketed as a spooky
hotel they [ __ ] with it a little bit but
it's more like it is a hotel but there
are certain lore that are [ __ ] and we
stayed in like one of the most haunted
rooms supposedly but we were we went
down to the isolation ward which is
where they would take passengers who
were sick and a lot of people died in
there and I laid there with the
recording tape recorder and we got a
voice and we still don't know what it is
so you were there with a normal everyday
tape recorder mhm
filming the white noise yeah you
couldn't hear it at the time no but when
you played it back you could hear it are
you yeah and it's really it's one of
those things where it's like I it was so
crazy that let's see it's right here cuz
I didn't I didn't know if we were really
gonna get much cuz you know when you
have cameras and like a light on stuff I
think ghosts maybe don't want to really
[ __ ] with you but this you can hear me
say guys cuz I thought my friends were
whatever cuz you were alone and kind of
scared and it sounded like it was like
feeding off you going like guys
[Applause]
I pulled up the wrong time but basically
I say guys Ian back there will he can
pull it up guys it was like a [ __ ]
voice and it's not one of these machines
cuz I've on ghost hunting and they have
these machines that like will just
randomly say [ __ ] cuz it's like an app
or something right this is just a
reporter so we're all recording and none
of us heard it it wasn't in the raw
footage like none of us heard anything
and then when we played it back that was
like something where I'm like okay that
was the first moment since my grandma
where I was like I literally can't
explain this everything else whatever
was coming out was like oh my god it was
did you feel spooked there or only
afterwards when you listen to that back
you're like look there because those
rooms are really scary like I went nine
years ago with a friend and something
pulled her pigtail in the middle of the
night and we like she's not a believer
but we went to the front desk I know
something happened there like we told Oh
something pulled her pigtails she goes
oh and the lady's like well it has been
known that the captain of the ship in
the middle then I used to walk around
poke girl's pigtails and then [ __ ] them
I was like that's yeah okay let's go to
our second break I want to pull up that
clip we'll find it during the break and
then we'll have a cued up ready for when
we get back so do not go away there
spooks and goofs to be had conspiracies
to be discussed and let's not forget
other stuff so don't go away we'll be
right back thank you to audible for
sponsoring this episode the HD podcast
audible needs no introduction at this
point they've got the best service the
best product if you're not on audible
what are you doing with your life for
our audience on audible is offering a
free audiobook with a 30-day free trial
if you want to listen to it audible has
it just go to audible.com slash h3
podcast or text h3 podcast to 500 500
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content download a title free and
start listening it's that easy whether
you want to
feel healthier get motivated learn
something new or just relax and kick it
audible has what you need imagine this
you're going for a run I imagine that's
what some people do you going for a swim
you're playing video games you can put
on a book you can learn something you
can be entertained while you're doing
that this is this kind of technology has
never existed in the world before we're
able to be productive on a level never
before imagined but seriously you can
enrich yourself and study and learn
while you're taking a run that's what's
so powerful and that's what I love about
audible specifically I've been listening
to Ernest Cline's ready player one which
has become almost like prolific in
today's culture if you guys haven't
heard about it
Spielberg is working on a movie about it
right now and it looks like a lot of fun
the movie the book is incredible it's
like a 80s 90s nostalgia space romp like
a cyberpunk kind of future Rob say romp
a lot describe it it's a total blast and
it's about like a vr MMO this whole
world is overtaken by this VR MMO game
like the world sucks but everybody's
plugs into this matrix and competing in
this super immersive world like I get it
bro I've you know I've played a world
Warcraft it's even crazier than that if
you can imagine such a thing it's a lot
of fun I highly recommend it it's
incredible
here's a cool thing about audible they
have a speed control you can listen at a
faster or slower pace depending on what
better suits you the narrator can slow
or speed his pace that sounds like it
shouldn't be possible that feels like
really cool it should only be possible
and ready player one the future is now
that is a very cool feature audible
members get a credit every month good
for any audiobook you guard las' of
price and unused credits roll to the
next month
and if you don't like an audiobook you
can exchange it no questions asked none
of this all really what chapter
specifically didn't you like it's not a
book report they trust you unlike your
teachers if you remember not personal
but audibles are great they're your
friend they J believe you they would
never accuse you of wine I've got
baggage get a free audio here's this is
too good to be true get a free audiobook
with a 30 day free trial at audible.com
slash h3 podcast or text h3 podcast all
one word - 500 500 that's audible.com
slash HTP podcast or text issue podcasts
- 500 500 for a free audiobook with a
30-day free trial thank you so much to
audible for supporting the nation and
finally thank you to clip oh my god I
love these guys gay let me see one of
these toothbrushes imagine a world where
a simple vibrating tube can be nominated
as Time Magazine's best invention of the
year a simple toothbrush what does this
simple toothbrush do well it cleans up
your disgusting mouth with style and
grace listen to this what this does you
turn it on and it times out three
minutes that's the perfect amount of
brush and every 30 seconds it gives you
a little pulsating it's just as if to
say keep going buddy you're doing great
keep it up and what three minutes is
done it turns off and you know you've
got the best brush but that's not all it
does it's got these really wonderful
like rubber heads and I am a stickler
for softness all toothbrushes I hate
like gum gum problems I do everything I
can to avoid having gum problems and
this is the best toothbrush I found it
has such a soft gentle head I get the
best brush of my life and I'm obsessed
with oral hygiene I can't endorse the
quip enough give it a try for pete's
sake guys it's it's by far one of my
favorite
hot freakin items Koopa loves it by the
way quip starts at just $25 and if you
go to get quick comm /h 3 right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at get quip
comm / H 3 spelled GE t qu i p.com / h 3
this is the refill you want bro this
thing looks like it's out of a
terminator film it like it came up from
the ground and there's smoke everywhere
like all you do is put this on every
three months comes with a little battery
unbelievable I cannot endorse this
product enough I love it and for $25 you
really have got nothing to lose by
giving it a try for the first time in
your life yes you somebody's gonna want
to kiss you and it's good you're gonna
like it so thank you to equip for
sponsoring us as well as audible if
you're in the market for any of those
please consider supporting the show and
by supporting our sponsors thank you so
much let's get right back into it
welcome back everybody today shri
podcast as promised let's get spooked
mm-hmm so here it is here's what we were
talking about with the recording
[Laughter]
oh that's what that's high pitch yeah we
have no idea what that well don't let me
go back because I'm maybe I don't think
I'm I think I missed it oh I thought it
was somebody that's me
okay but then it sounds like a metallic
it's creepy it sounds like a girl like
yeah that's what's crazy guys right oh
my god like it's so [ __ ] like bat
grabbed my ponytail specific area where
we heard that was in we're like so many
people died like because it went into
bed in the hospital right like okay okay
do you enjoy seeking it out like why it
does it do you do it for the V do you do
it for the viewers to create
entertaining content or does it give you
a thrill or do you like do you hate it
going and getting spooked or is it a
thrill I love it
I think for me I'm like a weird I always
know when there's a ghost tryna ever
since that experience I've just like
been really open to it so I enjoy it but
when something like that happens to real
it that to me felt like demonic like
that felt like we were [ __ ] with
something and I did not enjoy that and
later it [ __ ] me up for a while when I
was editing it I was like creeped out
like that I didn't really enjoy enjoyed
the rest of it right everything on that
boat felt kind of demonic there was like
this tapping in the closet right next to
our heads it sound like a like a
fingernail do you feel that demonic
forces can influence have a direct
influence on your life
god I don't maybe I don't have an answer
I'm just curious in and I don't know I
know that like there is evil in the
world right sure not like at what point
even the kid that and we'll get to the
shooting even the kid that shot at that
school so okay it's mental illness right
but if everybody and his family was like
no he was normal we didn't see anything
it's like so is that mental illness plus
actual evil cuz you have to be actually
even do that when was twisted right so I
mean he his fan well I don't know if you
know the story was back around
do you I know I saw like an interview on
good like he both of his parents died
and he was in foster care and then his
foster parents died like really awful
tragic background right but I mean
surely normal there are normal people
who are like right just evil I don't
know it's like a next level thing
because just normal mental illness it's
like there's so many people suffering
with mental illness you would think that
there would be even more crazy things
going on in the world but it almost
feels like it I don't know I'm not even
religious I don't know but I've
definitely felt like some evil [ __ ]
mmm and like when I see those stories on
the news I'm like that's so [ __ ] up
and evil like like how Sandy Hook like
literally why I'm like how ya know I
can't believe its unfathomable yeah I do
want to talk you know what why don't we
I wanted to talk about conspiracy videos
but why don't we just segue into where
we're going because I saw that you made
a tweet we'll come back to the
conspiracy videos because I I love this
[ __ ] this is so good but you I want to
go down here when we're talking about
the Florida shooting yeah let me start
by showing this tweet which basically
made me think like hey I want to talk to
Shane about this because I felt the same
way he said so [ __ ] heartbroken and
pissed at what happened in Florida I
just don't understand why the world is
so [ __ ] up sorry I don't have
something more eloquent to say I'm just
enraged and so sad and I felt the same
way I'm like man like it was exactly
what I was feeling when I saw that to it
people say it's like the eighth school
shooting and in one year 18 18 18 yes in
like three month two months
yeah I mean there's possible much wrong
with American society that's in it that
this [ __ ] keeps happening to these poor
[ __ ] kids when I was a kid I didn't
have any [ __ ] drills nobody expected
someone to come shoot up my school
apparently because I was listening to
these kids who were at the school
talking about like we've done drills
we're all prepared for this [ __ ] it's
like what this is part of what something
that they have to actually worry about
something that always pissed me off that
I think make it worse and it's funny how
much [ __ ] YouTube gets from the media
the media's coverage of these guys they
say their name they glorify them they
put them on the scoreboard the school
shooter high score list like it's a
[ __ ] arcade game like this guy got 18
it's the second most deadliest only by
these other two guys they have the high
score it's like stop saying their name
stop advertising their score it's part
of the allure and that I mean there's so
much more that's wrong but that one
always pisses me off because the media
has got this like do goodie like hey
we're just more in the facts but they
are doing it so that people watch and
they're selling ads on it and they're
marketing this [ __ ] this is a story that
I've I've mentioned several times the
podcast but just as a quick aside during
the Vegas shooting I was watching CNN
and they rolled a five minute long
commercial during the live broadcast
while that was happening and the same
brands like dr. pepper and coke coal and
all these sons of [ __ ] and it's like
it's just so sane
dude it's so sick yeah I said and we say
you know a dick joke and we can't get an
ad but you can advertise on people
actually dying like it's so crazy to me
it's easy works it is insane and it they
don't care that's why when the me to
thing happened you know and obviously
I'm all for that but what was
frustrating was you know all these talk
shows and all these news all this news
coverage of it was very much like it's
like first of all you all knew about how
Harvey Weinstein everybody knew the fact
that I knew and I'm not in Hollywood
yeah my mom knew and she's just going to
church in Starbucks and she knew yeah
it was a bad person so it's like that to
me it's like and do you even really care
you're just wanting clicks you're you
know I'm not a pedophile but that got
you clicks I don't really care so you
put the story out there it's like I
don't know using the kids the shooters
name and his face and his picture in
this and I endless stories about who he
was and what he did and yeah oh we're so
intrigued by this guy like it's like you
have people like Charles Manson who was
like fangirls because how the media
sensationalized him yeah it's like yeah
and they have like this huge breaking
story right after this Harvey Weinstein
actually raped 50 more women that we
thought coming up after this dr. pepper
ad yeah that's insane but that's one
part of it that really upsets me the
other part is it like this is a
polarizing issue but guys this is my
opinion okay I think that arming
teachers is an objectively insane she's
like I think that in an objective world
we're all like hey well here's a color
what color is that were like that's a
blue that's blue I think in a world as
objective as that giving teachers guns
is that [ __ ] insane it's pure lunacy
like on the way here we release into the
news and they were talking about how
this is the solution that is being
suggested now and they think Trump was
saying that they do maybe they can offer
bonus to teachers with guns we're
strapped weird evolving no gonna reward
a teacher based on if they have a gun or
not and not based on how well they know
physics right like let's not listen
let's for ignore actually teaching now
let's focus our bonuses on if you're
strapped imagine knowing like imagine
going back into school and knowing that
your teacher had a [ __ ] gun like I
was afraid my teacher would like take
away my Twizzlers or whatever imagine
knowing here she has a [ __ ] gun
yeah and my teachers and we talked about
this earlier then my teacher I had three
different teachers have mental
breakdowns in class why don't my
teachers got on a table screamed I'm
going to kill myself
are you this was in Long Beach
California oh okay yeah she was a nice
lady but she got a phone call sweet lady
rang she got a phone call just a second
kids and then she started crying and
we're all it's like oh my god and then
she hung up and another teacher came in
and comforted her her dad died in the
hospital then she gets another phone
call her brother died minutes later
because he had a heart attack watching
his dad died so she had these two things
happen and then somebody threw gum at
her the grieving woman got her hair she
got up on the table screams couldn't
kill herself through a chair and then
ran out we never saw her again imagine
if she had a [ __ ] gun crazy who knows
like so can teachers guns like listen
I'm not political at all like I'm not a
left or right I don't care I don't know
whatever but like to me the fact that
like all these people are like stop
politicizing you know the deaths of all
these kids right away let the families
grieve it's like well if we don't
politicize it right away people get over
stuff so [ __ ] fast yeah in a week
people are gonna be like anyways this
whole point doesn't make sense to me
I don't understand that I feel like
they're genuinely just deflecting the
actual I think the actual solution to me
is not selling ar-15s to mentally
unstable children yeah but they're
deflecting that with this what this
total [ __ ] proposition to give
teachers guns which is disingenuous
because it's insane and will never
happen and so just long enough so that
people forget and then we could move on
to the 19th shooting yeah Wow yeah cuz
like what what is the solution it's is
it I don't know anything about guns I
don't think we should take away guns I
don't care it's not like my thing but
like what is the solution is it taking
away so they shouldn't be able to buy
cuz the gun that he used was crazy
everything is I know it killed 17 people
in seven minutes that's the greaseless
or me maybe that's not the exact numbers
but something like that yes why do you
need that gun yeah what here I'm like in
the army you have guns like that okay
like even hunting and stuff like you
don't you know you're hunt
let me show you what a ar-15 looks like
this is the gun that is basically like
the favorite gun of a school a military
weapon semi-automatic it's got a huge
clip it's made to kill people and like
and neither of us is an expert on this
topic at all but why do we even need to
be experts to agree yeah so there's a
problem here and the thing that
frustrates me is like there's there's
two people okay guns like let's have
more and I don't believe that we should
take all guns away I think that we
should have common sense gun laws so
there's people who say and then people
dilute that even more it's like you're
against all guns or you're for all guns
I'm for common sense gun laws and so
that's one person and then the other
person is the way I see it there's a
problem you fix it it's clearly a
problem here happens so many times I
come from Israel and in Israel a lot of
times you'll have all of a sudden a new
trend a new trend of a new terrorist
trend you mean yeah a notorious trend of
stabbings oh my god and I don't know I
don't even know exactly what was the
solution but the country work on it and
then they figure a solution and then it
stops so this one seems so clear to me
so what I was gonna say that I remember
was there's
it's either gun control or mental health
so is like okay fine if the people who
are in charge think it's a mental health
issue what are you doing to address that
nothing so I don't understand but then
also the mental health thing confuses me
too because if you're have mental health
issues but you've never been to a doctor
a psychologist or anything can you just
walk in and buy a gun and there's no
proof that you have mental health issue
how did is there proof well I guess
they're saying it's like we need better
treatment for these people we need to
fix the issue before they go in and buy
a gun interesting
it doesn't seem I think both are good
but as far as I can see they're cutting
health care is becoming less accessible
so I see if that's what they generally
think it is it's becoming a worse oh
it's becoming less effective right I saw
someone say like 9/11 happened once and
nobody's used airplane
to crash into a building since then it
happened one time that is cruising 9/11
happen and it changed everything
I mean the security lines got longer you
know how many other things that's that
was the point I was trying to make yeah
so why you if you figure out there's a
problem that repeats itself yeah I don't
know I I actually made a list of reasons
keep dying just it seems like there's a
lot of reasonable people who think that
we should be arming teachers I made a
list of reasons why it's insane I don't
know how deep I want to get into this
there was a there was a deputy at the
school who was armed he was an officer
and when the shooting began he ran and
hit that is a trained deputy who was
there to protect the kids what is a
[ __ ] teacher middle-aged female a
woman or man who spends his time around
children supposed to do with a handgun
against the ar-15 assault rifle
I missed oh I'm dead with everybody yeah
and I shot a kid who was running because
I panicked oh my god you have KITT if
you have guns laying around deranged
kids are more likely to get them from a
careless teacher whatever all right
let's move passes let's talk about
conspiracy theories well speaking of the
shooting that's the biggest one right
now is the Raisa sector that's a good
place to start what do you think about
the tell me about what that conspiracy
is first so crisis actors are a
conspiracy I don't even know if it's a
conspiracy at this point because it's
well basically people think that the
media good sir well people think that
the media hires actors to pretend like
they were in the tragedy to be on camera
to be interviewed because normal people
that just saw their friend I probably
can't talk to a camera like they're too
late [ __ ] up so the news wants that
scoop so they hire like Tim to come over
here pretend like you were there and
Trustin you know so there's certain
people that have been at like the same
woman has been at Sandy Hook and she's
been at 9/11 and she's been at this is a
real thing so if you watched some of the
videos I think it's like sometime
the same people and it's not that crazy
to me because the news is [ __ ] crazy
so why wouldn't they just have roaming
actors right you know so they couldn't
use a different actor that seems like to
be changed a little bit think I'm a wig
or something and then glasses little
things this one woman they didn't do
very much to like she look very similar
same voice and everything um Wow Ian
pull up some of that [ __ ] I want to see
that God yeah I want to see that so the
latest one like the Sandy Hook dad have
you seen that video get me the Sandy
Hook dad goddamn it when I show
everybody because this is the one that I
actually can't explain because I don't
want to believe it but this dad who lost
a child was on the news that night and
he didn't know the camera was rolling
and he's like laughing and then he says
like are we rolling and then you see him
like very quickly turn mmm he's you'll
see changes you know it's very
interesting so people think he's at a
crisis actor okay and that you know
nobody's saying that the kids didn't die
nobody say well some people saw a lot of
John's had a conspiracy theory that it
was all of what he called a false flag
to steal guns and that that they're the
kids didn't exist to begin with
yeah that's pretty bananas yeah I don't
believe that the explanation of that
makes sense because as you said the
media is [ __ ] insane
yeah they want that interview they want
that sound bite for their like
commercial break you know like I was
there it was crazy
more coming soon um say when you see the
Sandy Hook dad that one's very
interesting grab that money and I want
to see the how do you call it if you
just type in you know Sandy Hook father
okay I think maybe which by the way no
disrespect I always say that no
disrespect like it but it is very
interesting to watch it's like
fascinating it's weird but so this new
kid there's a kid who you know people
think is a crisis actor because some of
his interviews have been a little weird
and you know people have seen him on
other news channels doing other things
previously he was in California at one
point saying he lived there but now he's
saying he lives in Florida whatever I
don't think he's a crisis actor but it
became a thing because Donald Trump's
son liked a tweet about it oh yeah yeah
you be as a public official like an
accusation like that on Twitter accusing
a child who's just survived a cool
shooting of being a [ __ ] phony
I know go to look in the yearbook you
idiot you're done here the president's
son just open a yearbook before you like
a tweet like that ya [ __ ] loser yeah
and people did look in the yearbook and
he's there so it's like he's not a crack
there they've been planning this for a
long time according to Trump jr. you can
please been in every yearbook again
objectively insane let's call the color
blue blue yeah you don't like a tweet
accusing a survivor of a school shooting
of being a phony yeah it's so tasteless
yeah that's crazy even as a youtuber I
wouldn't like that because I have some I
have some responsibility depression
so basically yet the could so there's so
what is the theory why are they using
this crisis at there well they're saying
all the kids are plants some people are
saying that's the thing it were my god
like I love conspiracies but those ones
are so crazy to me cuz it's like wow
there's if you go on like liveleak and
stuff like when a tragedy like this
happens as [ __ ] up as it is I do go on
websites and watch real footage of it
because I want it to really [ __ ] sink
in you want to actually understand how
[ __ ] it because then I get like
[ __ ] angry I'm like we need to figure
this out like there's footage of it I
didn't think about that but like when
the Vegas shooting happened like I was
really [ __ ] up over that cuz I [ __ ]
love Vegas and that really [ __ ] me up
so when I watch the actual footage of
that I'm like so horrified yeah and I'm
like anybody that thinks this didn't
happen like look at that it's like come
on you know oh yeah and and I mean that
just goes to show you how a custom we
we're we are used to children being
slaughtered we're like oh [ __ ] alright
this time it's really like I don't know
people are really tired of it I think
made me finally
there'll be some change even youtubers
like the fact that nothing changed as
far as VidCon I mean greets and stuff
after christina Grimmie i don't you
remember literally shot in the face
awful at a meet-and-greet where there's
like 20 people 20 kids it's like and you
go to VidCon and there's thousands of
thousands it's like and maybe they
didn't do security I don't know but for
me personally whenever I've done like
another being greed it's like no there's
not that much change you can still just
walk up and do it
mm-hmm I got that didn't wake anybody up
which is so [ __ ] up so but yeah
there's a lot of conservatives who are
using this crisis actor thing to
legitimize it say like these kids were
coached by CNN and all this stuff but
anyway that [ __ ] is so tasteless that
it's hard to convey let's talk about
something that's great and hilarious
let's start with the Mattress Firm
conspiracy which gave me in total
[ __ ] giggle let me pull this off so
give the audience a little it's
reference like Oh crazy just for me okay
so you're reporting first of all this
resonated with me cuz I'm like you're
right what's going on mattress stores
yeah so here let me just start by
showing this clip from your video Andrew
he told me a couple years ago he was
visiting his hometown in Al Ghanim
winter and he noticed that there were
three mattress firms on the same street
so I decided to pull up Google Maps and
check it out myself all right
Mattress Firm near Algonquin
three on the same street not just to
show you how close they are to each
other let's look at the satellite view
alright here's the first door now we're
just gonna go up the street two clicks
and then I mean that's crazy and he's
not the only person that has noticed
this there are tons of videos of people
driving around their city showing how
close and how many mattress firms there
are I need a mattress there's a story
but there's there's some places with
kids I've been tweeting like there's
some places where there's like 20 in a
city and I didn't really understand what
money laundering was no but when I
really looked into I'm like that makes a
lot of sense not I don't wanna get sued
but it makes a lot sense so wait money
laundering is when you like pretend to
have sales so yes people buy like super
marked up mattresses no so basically you
know back in the day Al Capone who was a
gangster made all this many millions of
dollars so he would buy laundry mats and
then take all his money spread it take
money to banks and say this is how much
we made it the laundromat okay and then
the bank million bucks exactly so long
so mattress stores mattresses are
expensive you can say oh yeah we sold
five thousand dollars of mattresses
today and just give them that fake money
and I don't know like that one to me
really makes sense
well our producer Dan was like there are
a ton of Matt what was your experience
with that then you have a mattress
stored thing oh yeah totally
I mean I've I've had this thought I
didn't know this was like a wider
conspiracy but in my neighborhood there
are tons of mattress stores with
products in there and no no customers
ever like nobody ever can it somehow
year they've been open for six years
Plus never seen a single soul in there
and
yeah there's definitely something fishy
going on so when I when I heard that I'm
not the only one I was and the company
that owns all the mattress stores I
think I cut it out of my video because I
don't want to get sued there's nothing
that owns all the mattress stores now is
in trouble for like fraud and stuff and
all their seat Wow left well the real
question is how are they making their
money what's are they laundry probably
drug money or something oh well this is
nothing I didn't put in there I didn't
know that I think it's five percent I
think five percent of money in the world
is black market money or like you know
dirty money from you know sex or drugs
or this or that and I think the number
was like eight hundred three hundred
billion it was like that high like
that's how much money is being like
laundered different places it's just
crazy
I guess I wonder if the government even
cares that one cuz when you're
laundering money you're paying taxes so
they're getting paid because you're
still you're like hey this is legit
income right so like I got my tax money
I got my fifty percent yeah
so these laundry stores are these
mattress stores are legit there's a
store by my house that I think is is
fake it's like a it's like a cupcake
shop and the cupcakes are clearly shitty
like we used to see stores like that all
the time in Israel like I'd walk by a
pastry store with the worst pet I go I'm
like you know I'm at Rhys place it's
like three days old and I walk by and
there's like all these middle-aged guys
hanging out the front I'm like you guys
are have to be laundering oh yeah crazy
there's a place up oh there's a place
not that far from here that's like a
soundstage and the front office of it
looks like Scarface it's a crazy crazy
furniture whatever and the guys that run
the place no [ __ ] like do whatever you
want 200 bucks for a whole day of a
really awesome soundstage I'm like there
is no way
[Laughter]
what other like kind of remarkable
strange conspiracies have you come
across like that because that one to me
was like I love because we've all been
to a mattress store and it's always
empty yeah there's like five salespeople
some of them I loved thinking about some
of them are really dark I mean I've got
we have some funny one way I pick some
out from I never heard of this
apparently everybody knew this about me
Murph's is an allegory for the KKK what
and then like dan or alex back there was
like yeah look at the villain from
Smurfs all right oh yeah been awhile
since I've seen The Smurfs and I pulled
it up ago like you anti-semitic yeah
that's what my grandpa looks like but
that's cuz yeah it is like Walt Disney I
don't I don't know all the history of it
but yeah a lot of people that used to
run all those places were like kind of
racist and kind of [ __ ] up just like
good old way good old boys like when you
really look back at some of those
cartoons like it's crazy that somebody
put it I mean like the black caricatures
how they used to portray like black
people in the 30s and [ __ ] was so racist
bro yeah that's crazy
that one was was I had a good laugh at
tell me more about this one Rebecca
Black's song Friday is about JFK
assassination I have a history with
Patrice Wilson too so I love to hear
what the hell that means
I don't really remember that was like I
remember being creeped out by it I
remember it was a joke but then it
creeped me out
something about everything she was
saying in the song like correlated with
the actual assessment because like her
wreck riding in the backseat right guy
in those fancy gave me the chills
because it's not bodies in the grassy
take
Jesus is an alien oh that one to me
doesn't even feel like a conspirator
that one's just self-explanatory
yeah right like but that's so all like
all the old paintings and all that stuff
and even in the Bible my mom used to
explain to me like how they would say
Jesus would like come and talk to people
and it was there was UFOs in the Bible
there is something else but it's like
from the other world comes this thing
that's cylinder like it's in the Bible
and I'm all the painting sethi Salou
UFOs and stuff and to me it's like Jesus
can like supposedly you know do magic
and heal people every alien movie you
sees the same thing healing people with
their touch my fingers like and all the
primitive guys are like it's magic but
he's just like hey it's not magic it
needs a little [ __ ] my Zippo that
won't make sense Jesus is an alien now
cardi B is an Illuminati puppet crack me
up because there's this moment where she
pauses right okay that moment to me like
of course when I first saw it on Twitter
I like laughed and then the more I
watched it and the more I showed people
the like when you watch it three times
it gets weirder let me pull it up like
it's so weird like she clearly is just
like kidding Dean this is her being
interviewed so there's a clip of Al
Roker having a stroke he's just like
yeah for a long time like way more
intense let me start here acted but
what's the conspiracy exactly what does
this have to do with the Illuminati that
you paused so people think that a lot of
celebrities are under you know like a
hypnosis mind-control type of things do
and that when you break out of it or
that when you talk about breaking out of
it they kind of turn you off which might
have been what they did to Britni and
Amanda Bynes and all these people that
very publicly lose their minds during an
interview or maybe this not that my new
I mean I think people nobody really
believes this I don't think okay it is
like when you watch it a few times
it's really weird let's have a look
being echoed nervous a little bit
shaky she didn't reference okay didn't
say like haha and the interviewer didn't
say like she did but like why what's he
trying to be funny
that's what I said let me just try to be
funny but when I'm trying to be funny
and I and it's like not that funny or
something I say something anyways just
kidding
she didn't wants to joke about just
feeling like I don't know or like that's
funny person yeah I saw him tonight Sean
weird right like maybe she was just
joking spit I'm gonna show you man so
nervous a little bit over 100
[Applause]
[Music]
and keep watching the people behind her
who I've learned now one of them is her
sister but the people behind her look
over at the same moment and then when
they look away she like comes back it
was it's very like you know what she's
like I don't know I feel a little weird
I feel a little so maybe that was the
joke she's I feel a little weird right
and then she's like but then wouldn't
she say something after wouldn't she be
like oh that shows dude man so yeah
anyway that one is interesting whatever
she's been afflicted by they really
[ __ ] al roker up yeah let me pull that
I've got this one while ago and it we
gotta watch it again yeah this is one of
the trickiest things I've ever seen
[Applause]
keep in mind
35 years ago we passed away the king of
rock and roll is Mark Cohen says there's
a pretty little thing waiting for the
king down in the junk that that I've
seen a deaf person die before that's
what it looks like it literally looks
like that I swear to God I was like he's
having a stroke
but apparently he's fine well but then
there's other clips of him getting
hypnotized on The Today Show and it
looks the same so people think that
something might have triggered him and
like I'm a conscious decision to do that
Yeah right I mean why would you
consciously just well why would Wendy
Williams like when you saw that why did
she grab her brain and stuff you know
when she passed out and she gained it
was such like a oh and then when she
came back she's like I was dehydrated
I'm like what I don't know but like I
think something went on as possibly her
vision was blurry and so she's like he
said she was going for her crown to make
sure her crown stayed on that show I
like that she comes to our hosts yeah
but then when they talk too much she
tell them shut up yes get dark what do
you got Reggie Watts the Sandy Hook dad
of course I haven't got it did you guys
find the sandy couldn't find it without
like annoying commentary did you guys
find it no I would all the videos I
could find have text on the screen when
it x-files music in Texas yeah it was I
couldn't find the ruffle that's a shame
um all right well c'est la vie
sandy hug dad we're here has they know
ever fun tried to figure out does this
guy hat have family photos with the I
remember me back when it first went on I
remember a lot of people found out that
he was an actor and he had like you know
resume and he had been in plays and
stuff which doesn't prove anything just
shows he's an actor but yeah there was a
lot of that like oh that's not his real
kid and stuff but I didn't really get
too much into that cuz that that to me
is just too [ __ ] up if he's not an
actor I feel really bad for him yeah
that's who now now I would never talk
about it in a video like when I made the
video about him it was like three years
ago or something now I would never do
that because it's like that's why I
haven't talked about the other crisis
actor kid because I'm just like that's
just yeah yeah target uses skinny
mirrors that one I didn't think was
gonna even happen I was just like oh
this will be kind of funny and then when
I actually did take pictures in the
target mirror versus really I mean I
know that doors skinny because skinny
mirrors are real like they went on Shark
Tank they did this whole thing yeah oh
yeah it's very real but like in target
I've always realized that I like what I
look like in Michael I don't like what I
look like I hate it less then I hate
less investor slogan no that one would
the before and after pictures were
pretty crazy but now nervous target
might get mad at me I don't know but
so in these conspiracy theories yes you
take them all very serious in the video
you you're like for example you had a
video about the moon as a hologram I
think you know oh no when it's vacuum
crazy I always say that first like this
one's crazy I like I obviously don't
believe is the moon real I think so a
lot of people don't they're just a lot
my brother is still like earth is flat
hundreds you want to own brother yeah I
want to like and I want to sit with him
and do a video about it cuz he genuinely
he's like I will prove it to you I'm
like that's the one where my I can't
what does he say about the Elon Musk car
and space with the live cam does he
think the elands in on the conspiracy I
didn't talk to him about that but that
when that did happen I was like oh I
guess this is gonna shut down a little
flat or a thing but it made it even
bigger
now more even more people like that was
fake it's funny it's interesting that
you your own bread cuz I've long
suspected that is a bunch of trolls and
that nobody actually believes people
always say like no one really believes
that but that's interesting
well that's but then like when you think
about it back when the 911 conspiracy
started everybody was every if you
publicly talked about that you were a
troll an idiot this is that and now it's
like most people if you ask like do you
think there was my 9/11 was an inside
job
like 50/50 or gonna be like yeah fifty
you they yeah there was some website
that I think was Wall Street Journal
somebody did a thing on it or they
pulled people in just fifty percent that
thought that there was some [ __ ] going
on but it's different levels of it yeah
yeah I don't think it didn't happen do I
think the government had some plans in
it like there's too many things pointing
to yes what is your opinion on the JFK
assassination the classic most time held
conspiracy that one honestly like I
haven't even really gotten into that one
mm-hmm just because I it doesn't excite
sounds [ __ ] up that's fair no that's
fair I don't get like it sold it sold it
sold mean any time I've like went into
it and stuff I'm just like I don't know
him fair enough
that was probably some somebody else
yeah yeah okay alright let's do a hard
twist here you had a podcast Shane and
Friends it just disappeared one there
right oh like what happened to your
podcast so the theory so yeah that was
[ __ ] up um I don't even I haven't even
made a video or anything about it
because I don't know what I'm allowed to
say or what I should say cuz it's so
confusing basically full screen which
was where the podcast was AT&T bought
full screen and then AT&T was like mmm
we don't like the app or something which
is where we were so like a lot of people
like a lot of people lost their jobs
like which is so [ __ ] up very quickly
with no like no that's insane you had a
contract with them right I had just
signed like for two more years or
something Wow
and they're just like smell you later
yeah I mean the guy that runs fullscreen
I love him I've known him for
ever he created the partner program on
YouTube like he's old right right right
even he was like maybe I should say he I
don't think that he knew it was very
like I think it shocked everybody mmm
you know for me I don't care about the
money I don't care whatever but like my
co-host that was her only form of income
and now like she's out of a job so
that's been really hard so are they they
surely must be somewhat accountable if
you had a contract they can't just can
they just breach I might be like sorry
new company I smell you later I don't
think so especially it's a yeah this is
like hey it's a million dollars just
yeah exactly
so I'm kind of waiting to bring back the
podcast cuz I don't know what's going on
cuz huh some people they're like well no
we're still gonna make it cuz we owe you
the money we might as well make it we'll
just put it on another platform that
makes sense that's I don't know what's
going on that so I'm just kind of
waiting how long has it been on hiatus
forced hiatus since like Christmas damn
yeah these big companies man they're
jerks guess what I found so would you
consider just doing it back on your own
if nothing I want to achieve figured
switcher would hate for it mm-hmm and
like timewise cuz I want out like you
guys have like a team and something I
want to do that yeah I just don't know
how to pay for that yet um I may have
something interesting to talk to you
about I was gonna I have a business
proposition
have you considered doing that like your
own podcast network yes we've just
talked about know if I'm supposed to
talk about this stuff cuz it's an ocean
but I don't give a flippin heck um we've
been talking with well don't say sorry
but we already brought it up we were
thinkin cuz we already figured out
everything yeah and [ __ ] we have
friends who know that want to do the
podcast maybe we can help them yeah
production has actually become a
production company it's like why don't
they youtubers band together and say
like no we all have podcast let's all do
it together and figure it out versus
like you know I mean yeah I might take a
little while to get no real money going
but it's like it's that's better than
having the rug pulled out I'll say this
my dream is to build a dream studio and
to be able to produce podcasts for
multiple different people well
just kind of like swap out the backdrop
change the lights a little bit
and everybody has a really beautifully
produced well shot podcast and and we
have it so streamlined here like it's
been a year of kind of grueling trial
and error for us and I think like we
really have a turnkey solution for four
people to do it so I think that'd be
really cool yeah we'll talk about that
but let's talk about this who somebody
found was sent to us let's see so this
is the what do we
Robbie Parker so again the backstory is
that he's a Sandy Hook dad who some
people say is a crisis actor mm-hmm well
in a situation like this I remember at
Virginia Tech when I went out there
parents loved ones of slain young people
wanted to remember their sons and their
daughters and as a result they spoke and
made a statement
we'll see if Parker and make a statement
looks like the family is there and
they're getting ready to make okay hang
on family is there they're getting
viki's in what is this video wrong with
this skin oh well it's when you see it
like that like when you see it full vert
full quality its he says are we are we
are we getting started are we rolling
and he's laughing he's looking back
you're laughing and then he goes into
the and then once he starts talking it's
like it's a very big switch it's like my
name is like it gets like very it just
oh it's very unsettling
everybody I've showed has been like ah
I'll say this it is completely within
the realm of possibility that the media
but it could also be that it was just
like a nervous yeah yeah yeah performing
something that's pretty ballsy of the
media to be like pretend that you're the
father of someone who was murdered in
the school shooting that seems so ballsy
or are they thinking like they're doing
a good service because it's like well
the actual father is too emotional to be
on camera but we want his story to get
told let's have somebody portray it
almost like the neighbors and people who
know this guy wouldn't they immediately
say like hey that's not him
sometimes it happens like with your
thing going on right now that's
happening with that I don't remember it
was a while ago I don't remember there
is one girl that everybody thinks is a
crisis actor and she's like publicly
come out and been like I'm not you're
ruining my life by saying this stop so
in reference to which event somebody saw
her at claims they saw her at three
different shootings there was a movie
theater and Sandy Hook I think and then
another one that one I never believed in
like that's a different girl
mm-hm and I don't really believe but I
definitely think it's not crazy like the
idea of the news hiring I mean the idea
the new scripts so many things like that
thing that just came out with CNN like
it's so many things are on CNN well
there was a couple things there is one I
think two years ago that CNN got caught
like actually faking a crime scene like
there was like two
tripods with the caution tape and the
ones like we're here it's like a live
crime scene and then somebody took a
picture from the crew like it's not and
you know what a dad was like oh well you
know technically there was another one
like yesterday were a kid from the
shooting was like CNN handed me a script
and told me exactly what to say and told
me not to say sir right I'm like that's
a little weird but I don't think the
events never happened like they happened
you know yeah this is my favorite fake
news moment this is the greatest moment
in this casting is in Wayne New Jersey
this morning you know that's funny luck
no you're gonna love this good morning
obviously we're getting a nice break
from the rain but not the flooding this
is essentially this guy's like [ __ ] yeah
my house is flooded ain't got time for
this [ __ ] you know it's funny and
light-hearted but in a way it's like
they're perfectly comfortable goofin the
truth well even in Vegas all those
people that were there saying I heard
another shooter I heard multiple
shooters I heard two really that's a
theory I didn't know that one girl very
adamant she was there she's like I saw
another gunman hmm what the Vegas
there's no information about that I know
a lot of people are angry and they're
like what actually happened because the
FBI is not releasing any information
about this guy why he did it
they're like oh there was a note in the
room and they're not saying what it was
no we don't even know the guy's motive
do we the theory
well I don't know his motive the theory
though that I don't even know if I
believe but it seems possible is that he
was actually working for the FBI and it
was supposed to be like a sting
operation where they were going to like
coax Isis people into this hotel room
with like a potential like gun trade or
some because yeah like a bathtub full of
guns whatever in order to catch them or
something and then when the ISIS people
got there they like kill them took the
guns and did the shooting themselves
that one seems crazy to me
but because we don't know anything else
you know Jesus
imagine well if that is what happened
they would be like we need to make sure
that people know that we didn't [ __ ] up
that bad
that's exactly so it's like if that did
happen of course the government they
never gonna let anybody know about that
because I'm sure that like sting
operations all the stuff happens
probably all the time right so it's like
if one goes wrong right just blame it on
this you know so far down the meme hole
yeah yeah here's some questions let's
hear I got some calls and multiple uh
let's see what conspiracy theory okay
let's try this one call let's talk with
Dominique Dominique you are on with Shan
dasa oh oh thanks man I appreciate you
god bless you they don't oh my god my
question is what was the first
conspiracy that kind of got you hooked I
know mine was 911 that kind of spooked
me even though being young my parents
told me like they lived in New York at
the time but still I knew somebody's a
little sketch and I want to know what
was your first experience in getting
like what the [ __ ] is going on with
these conspiracy theories thank you hey
thanks guys I appreciate you man thanks
man do the best 9/11 was a big one
but also there was a movie that I don't
know if you guys saw I feel like
everybody saw it and it ruined their
life for like a month it's called I
think sight guys and I know I've seen it
but some I think honestly I don't smoke
weed but there was like a year of my
life during high school where I was
stoned all the time and I think that's
when I watched that and it's all a blur
yeah when I watched it ruined my life
for like a month because it basically is
saying everything's fake and God's not
real and aliens it's just like
everything's like not real okay and that
like was like what's the point of life
no a month of that but that conspiracy
idea of like nothing being
real everything's fake whatever mixed
with the 911 stuff because my mom at the
time was so like loved Bush loved Bush
whatever I don't know what she would say
now but when I watch that loose change
documentary about 9/11 listen I was
young and I was like oh my god I showed
my mom and even she was like wait a
minute we there is something off like
that's when I was like oh my god II
think you're saying all right and I'm
crazier so yeah all the 9/11 cephalic
I'm still okay that everyone what's a
fact about 9/11 that you think is like
if you if everyone only knew this fact
they would know that it was a conspiracy
bombs went off in the building before
any planes hit and I've heard that but I
am not sure that I've seen compelling
evidence to support oh yeah there's this
guy he was a janitor and he was at 9/11
saved like 20 people's lives got like a
medal for it all this stuff and he was
doing you know pressed tours about it
and when he would do the pre-interview
he would tell them like well you know
the bomb happened in the lobby at where
I was before the plane hit like why is
nobody whatever and they'd always tell
him don't bring that up don't bring that
up don't bring that up
so they would tell him not to talk to
someone change no this wasn't you yeah
this is a whole separate he did like a
whole thing about it there was that
there was people that were there in the
lobby when the bomb went off that have
done interviews like right away on the
news back when it first happened like
there's interviews from the news of
people being like there was a bomb in
the lobby there's bomb lobby there's
like firemen saying like there was a
bomb in the lobby like there's all this
footage of it and you can even hear it
like in footage you can hear it's that's
the craziest part to me so it's like and
the government's like why not just say
like oh the terrorists put bombs in
Lobby just say that like what I don't
know who did it but somebody did it they
were there so what was that also oh
people that were working in the building
so one building got hit by a plane and
then the other building you would think
would evacuate obviously but on the
intercom it was telling them stay hmm
everybody stay why like this one guy in
this documentary was like I was staring
out the window and I saw a colleague of
my jump and on the intercom as that's
happening they're saying everybody stay
you're fine you're safe
he's like why were they telling me to
stay why weren't they telling me to get
out and then right after that they plane
at the second building things like that
I'm like what just doesn't make sense I
guess they didn't want I mean I guess
the explanation being that they didn't
want panic yeah they I mean surely
nobody maybe it seemed dangerous that
the first building would collapse
so you safer if you stay right inside I
don't think anybody okay assuming it's
not a conspiracy I don't think anyone
anticipated that the buildings could
possibly collapse I don't think that was
a possibility in anybody's mind
Wow the bigger theory is that the
government planted bombs in the building
drove off so that the building would
collapse because from what everybody
says there's no possible way that the
building's could have collapsed from a
plane hitting it and buildings nearby
collapsing for no reason what just like
doesn't make any so what was the end
goal of the government in doing that
people think that the government did
this false flag did this love there to
struggle or yeah right that's the I
guess yes which like seems far-fetched
obviously for me I don't believe all of
the 9/11 things but I do think if
there's fucked-up [ __ ] going on this so
do you think that Bush was involved or
was it a different agency altogether
I don't know was Dick Cheney I'm sure he
do anything Cheney was involved he's
basically sitting on the Death Star
right now yeah well he's the oil guy
that was the weird Martin was a he was
like directly profiting well if you
watched the loose change documentary the
day or two before 9/11 happened Bush's
brother like went to the World Trade
Center and like didn't like a look
through and the basements and all the
different like but nobody knew why just
very strange so people think like you
know I'm torn on that basis you don't
yeah I don't I personally I believe the
mattress firm mattress is real we can
all agree those matches people are up to
no good the 9/11 one and I'm stretch I
it's a real stress for me because when
you well it really depends how you
approach it cuz you can look for the
conspiracy theories I think you can also
look for the debunkers and they're both
they could both be really compelling
because when you when I'm like okay so
people say that you know the beam jet
fuel can't melt
steel beams or whatever and then you
read about some engineers and the like
well actually it can't it can not melt
it but it makes it into a weakened state
where it's more malleable and then once
the top floor where the planes hit
crashed then it creates a domino effects
and they all come tumbling down the jet
fuel melted down this metal beam and it
didn't melt it but by heating it up it
makes it less dense and therefore less
stable right yeah here with your logic
the black box thing is weird too did you
hear about that Oh what is that so you
know every plane has a black box yes oh
yeah and they're indestructible but
indestructible right and that's how they
find out what happened on the plane why
did it go by were different the both
black box is three both in the planes in
the World Trade Center and the one that
crashed
United 93 all the black boxes melted
which is like how they say it else it I
mean to me it makes it's reasonable to
say it was lost because it was in the in
the middle of literally one of the
largest building the world crumbling to
its foundation so saying it was
destroyed our loss sounds reasonable
doesn't it I don't know black diamonds
aren't made of like paradox material
like they're made of something but the
one in the field is crashed yeah that
looks like where's the black box things
like that are just like I don't think it
was like fake I don't think I think
people died I think it was awful yeah
but I also feel like the news I feel
like everything gets kind of covered up
just like the pedophile thing with me
it's like nobody was saying like oh but
also this isn't a real allegation is it
they didn't care about that it was just
like I'll click whatever and also I
always think about it like YouTube so
the government write on YouTube when
you're vlogging you pick up your thing
heyguys blah blah you put it down that's
real but not really it's kind of like
what you're showing them the government
could be youtubing we're showing you
what we want to show you
we're not going to show you you know the
real [ __ ] going on behind that's a good
enough like do that I don't know
fighting you know what I mean my opinion
is the best counter-argument to the
conspiracy 9/11 you're giving the
government way too much credit
so incapable of pulling that off and not
having one person within a high-ranking
I shouldn't leave be like yeah you know
this guy Jeff he's a real [ __ ] I
don't think they did it but I think they
knew it was gonna happen and I think the
people that did it that's interested
bombs and I think it was way bigger and
I think when it did happen the
government was like [ __ ] we can't admit
that there was bombs cuz that shows that
there was planted so you think it's more
about covering up incompetency rather
than a plan because that makes more
sense to me that's more believable
just like the news right now with the
fact that the FBI knew that this kid
wouldn't want to be school shooter and
do anything but like back in 2001 when
9/11 happened we didn't have twitter we
didn't have all these things so i'm if
9/11 happened now I guarantee you we
would know all the like fuck-ups we
would know everything mm-hmm so I think
they're just hiding things I think right
that makes sense to me and it could be
like little things that you don't even
really matter or they could be bigger
things like who set up 9/11 was it
bigger than just like dude what's a
super [ __ ] crazy man crazy though
that just like the fact level is pretty
unbelievable just a couple dudes with
the box cutters was just like make sense
to me cause so much man crazy they were
innovators man they were like dude let's
do something never no one's ever thought
of doing before also thousands of people
died isn't it crazy thousands of people
died most people since Pearl Harbor it
is kind of on it's it's really hard to
fathom what was it like 59 in Vegas I
think how many single dynasties yes how
many died in 9/11 I think several
thousand thousand I think around three
thousand three k plus Dan says well well
let's you know what I want to end on a
positive note okay let's not end on 9/11
victims let's end on everybody's time
hello and favorite news conspiracy
theory D bomb Matt Lauer
yeah frickin weirdo you've been debunked
Matt Lauer had a rape button under his
desk Wow
this whole thing is is bankrupt Matt
Lauer
in the Northeast as more rain continues
to fall today and Matt Lauer he seemed
like such a sweet family guy he's got a
rape button I never trusted him really
if you for those guys you don't know
apparently Matt Lauer
he had a button so when people walked in
his office and we got this [ __ ] and it
will lock them in there with him so we
could get weird and let she on him yeah
dude that's like supervillain [ __ ] Oh
he'd be like hey Lauren come in here
she's a [ __ ] now clicked his rape bun
not a joke bro it's diabolical it's like
wow that's so twisted it's funny
and then there's certain people that
haven't had a me-too about them that you
would think would spend supers on
YouTube to like we all know who the
creepy ones are some of us don't have
concrete evidence but like we all know
that you have names like I don't wait I
don't I feel like I don't know I never
get a VidCon yeah and I heard that
that's like pure debauchery oh my god
that's the fact that Matt hadn't become
a huge scandal it's not I've heard from
people who go there it's just a bunch of
underage underage girls chasing their
favorite youtuber around what do you got
to say because I don't know I don't know
not even relevant in your Blake back in
the day it was a lot more like there was
always like a few that everybody's like
a stay away from that 100 I think I know
who you're talking about there's like a
few of those so the fact that now none
of those you know it's it's interesting
I know who you talk to mom but not Lauer
man it's hard to top a rape button you
know it's just time held classic and
little canoe lady it's a good memories
man it's a good time she's in the
community this morning so here we are
Alicia's and on a break now here
nobody's dying
being tortured nobody's being brave
buttoned just a great little gap dum-dum
condemning down a lightly flooded street
not even flood really bought it couple
guys are like you know what's funny
she's like it's so hard to control me I
wonder if she was like not aware or if
she's just like I'm there's no turning
back I'm not gonna like get up and she's
like I wanna see more videos like this
who just harmless stupid oh he called
her out actually Michelle I'll take it
is there some kind of severe drop I'm
have to see you in my office later sir
after the report that was that shows how
evil he is the fact that he's calling
her out and feeling into it and by the
way by the way you probably knew
beforehand - oh yeah all right we're
gonna do this little canoe bit wrap this
up I'm so embarrassed I'm just gonna as
she canoes off into the song I want to
thank you shame for coming it was so fun
to meet you and chat with you and good
you're cool man I'm really happy to see
you doing well lately your channels is
killing and everybody all all your fans
seem super stoked on the content and
everything you're doing so I wish you
well thank you and continued success
Shane Dawson obviously by now you know
who I'm talking to
um Shane it's easy to find on YouTube
shame you have anything else you want a
year working on that you want to talk
about hopefully bringing the podcast
back more videos sweet goodbye how cool
is that you're just Shane on YouTube
you're just like I'm Shane
there's nobody Dawson he doesn't what he
does things with trash cans I don't know
it's like a weird set yeah there's a
couple videos check them out alright
guys thank you so much for watching um
it's been around total rock it's been a
ball tune in we'll be back Friday we're
gonna be doing a top of the month we
don't have a guest scheduled but we are
gonna be guaranteed to be talking about
some things you really disturbing weird
stuff that you probably don't want to
hear about if that's not a selling point
then I don't know it is anyway see you
guys alright
Tata thanks guys
[Music]